Right now the thing that is keeping x from being by itself on this side is this
plus 3 right here. If that weren't part of the equation, if we just had for
example, x equals 12; then we wouldn't have very much work to do. We'd already
have a solution to our equation. However it is here, so we need to figure out
how to get rid of it. So how do we undo addition? Subtraction.
To make it so that nothing extra is added to the left side, we need to subtract
3 from the left side. That will make it so this entire side of our equation says
x plus 3 minus 3. Now if we saw this as just an expression, we would know how to
simplify that. The 3's would just cancel one another out since 3 minus 3 is 0
and we would have x plus 0 or just x. That's a super important step in moving
forward in solving our equation. But wait, important. Whatever we do to the left
hand side of the equation, we also have to do the right side, so we make sure
that these 2 sides are still equal to one another, so I need to put in minus 3
here underneath the 12 as well.